we've seen plenty of Transformers games
over the years but the latest is
something totally new transformers earth
Wars is a real-time strategy game from
Hasbro and space ape games the team
behind rival kingdoms it's the first RTS
starring everybody's favorite robots in
disguise the mobile game will let you
leave the Autobots is Optimus Prime or
command the Decepticons is Megatron as
you battle over Energon stockpiles and
you build space bridges to bring in
reinforcements from Cybertron bumblebee
and Starscream have also been confirmed
even better peter cullen and frank
welker are reprising their respective
voice roles as Optimus Prime and
Megatron they'll be speaking lines
written by Simon Furman who's worked on
comic series like Judge Dredd and alpha
flakes transformers earth wars hits iOS
and Android this spring and it'll launch
for free with available in app purchases
you can get it worldwide except for
Japan and China but no matter where in
the world you are keep it locked to
gamespot for all your Transformers news
you